glab kuznetsov is a Long Way From Home
he had a life back in his hometown St
Petersburg but when war broke out he
knew what he had to do
we were on our way here we didn't know
whether we would stay here or move
elsewhere our objective was just to get
out of Russia and to look around and
then make a decision
glaab is one of thousands of Russians
who fled to Georgia to avoid fighting on
the front lines he started a business as
carving out a new life but he's found
that newcomers aren't being welcomed
with open arms
we've had virtually no Georgian
customers there were a few people who
worked nearby who would drop by for a
coffee but you could count them on one
hand
anti-russian graffiti is everywhere the
two countries have a fraud history
they went to war over Breakaway regions
in 2008. many Georgians became refugees
in their own country and bitterness
remains
the new arrivals also pushed up housing
prices further stoking resentment
they're not our friends they're our
enemies it's a fact and them doing
business here and drinking with us is
just plain wrong terrible I would say I
wouldn't go into a russian-owned cafe I
want to support Georgian businesses
but some are seeking to build Bridges
here at this bar Russians are studying
the Georgian language those reaching out
to this new community believe acceptance
may come with time
the Russians who fled the war have only
just arrived we have not got acquainted
yet we don't know each other well we are
not used to each other
both communities may have no choice but
to learn how to coexist
there's no telling how long the war in
Ukraine will last so for now at least
Georgia's Russian Exiles may be here to
stay
Fenton Monaghan Al Jazeera